So why did they do this? Because the
Lord's prayer, Father, may be may the
may they be one as we are one, perfected
in unity, so that the world may know
and believe you have sent me.
John 17:11 20-23.
A unity which is of course to be
expressed visibly. Why visibly? Because
the Lord said, "Do you want to convert
the world?
You want the world to be converted?
You want the world to be converted and
be saved?
Do you want the world to be converted
and be saved?
Love one another with perfect love.
Unite to one another with perfect unity.
And that will be a testimony to the
world that this must be an act of God
because there's no way for corrupt
humans to be perfectly united unless
it's a divine work.
That's what the Lord said. I'm going to
show you the words of the Lord himself
so that we can better respond to Lord's
call for the unity of his own. A unity
which has of course to be expressed
visibly to overcome these obstacles. We
now establish a mixed committee for
theological dialogue between the
Catholic Church and Syrian Church of the
East. All right.
What did the Lord say would result in
the conversion of the world? Now, sadly,
because we are sinful, corrupt, tainted
by sin and pride, and also tempted by
Satan and demons, that perfect unity
will only be realized when Jesus
returns. You know what that means? the
whole world will not be saved. You know
whose fault? Our fault.
How do I know? Let me show you.
The Lord said, "The world will convert
and believe and know
that God sent me
and that
God loves the church as he loves me
and that I'm in the church
by their perfect union love for one
another."
There it is.
You understand? According to John, to
know
to know
that the father sent the son is to have
eternal life. To believe that the father
sent the son is to have eternal life. So
if the world comes to know and believe
that God sent the son, that's the
salvation of the world. And he left it
up to you. He's saying the world will be
saved when you
become perfectly united one another.
Love one another with a perfect love the
way the father and I and spirit love one
another and are perfectly inseparably
united because that will be a testimony
to the world. This cannot be of man.
It is impossible for humans to become
perfectly united and love one another
perfectly because humans have tried from
the beginning and they fail miserably
over and over and over again.
So the fact that the church could be
perfectly united and separately united
and in love with one another as the
godhead is in love with one another.
That would be a miracle to the world.
This has to be a work of God.
Let me show it to you.
Not for these only do I pray. John 17:20
to 23
right here.
But for those also who will believe in
me through their word. Look, do you know
to this day the apostles are converting
the world. What do I mean? Though
physically not with us, they're alive in
heaven as this embodied spirits. Their
preaching is still with us. It's in the
Bible and the church. Anytime I read the
Bible to you or I quote the words of the
apostles, they are preaching through me,
through you. This is what the Lord is
saying. Not only them, but all who
believe through their word to this day.
It's their word that's being preached
through us leading to conversions. That
means till this day, Peter, Paul, John,
Thomas, they're converting souls and
winning souls to Christ
because we're preaching their message
inspired by the spirit, preserved by the
spirit.
You understand the teaching here?
You understand what we're reading here?
Right? All right. Now, let's read about
the unity.
Yeah, because it's already two hours in.
See, spirit's will be done.
Even as you, Father, are me and I in
you, that they also may be one in us.
See, that the world may believe that you
sent me. When will they believe? That
they may all be one, just as father,
son, and spirit are one. Now, what kind
of unity do they have? Perfect,
unselfish,
selfless unity.
Okay,
Rumble, you got it.
And then the world will believe that you
sent me. The glory which you have given
me, I've given to them that they may be
one even as we are one. Because God does
not override your human choice.
He works with you and energizes you to
submit.
But you can resist because of sin. I in
them and you in me that they may be
perfected into one that the world may
know that you sent me and love them even
as you loved me. God the Father loves
every baptized believer member of the
body of Christ as much as he loves
Christ. And that's what Jesus wants
because he's not selfish. But
here's the problem.
Jesus just said, "If you are perfectly
united, the world will know and believe
that the father sent the son." Well,
according to this chapter, if you know
and believe
that Jesus Christ was sent by the
father, you will obtain eternal life.
Here it is. John 17:3.
Rumble. You got it. [clears throat] This
is eternal life that they should know
you, the only true God, and him whom you
sent, Jesus Christ. Wait. If eternal
life is yours by knowing the father's
only true God and knowing that he sent
Jesus Christ
and Jesus says by your perfect union,
your perfect unity, the world will
believe that the father sent the son and
will know that the father sent the son.
That means it's salvation for the world.
You guys know what that means? You are
the obstacle. I am the obstacle. I am
the reason that the world is not coming
to salvation. Cuz when they see my
hypocrisy and my hatred, and when they
see the infighting, David Wood calling
me out, me calling him out,
they see how disgusting we are, they're
like, "Man, this is Christianity. You
can keep it. We don't want it."
Right?
So who is the cause of this prayer not
being fulfilled? Believers.
How many times you have heard from
people
saying Christians are a bunch of
self-righteous snobs and hypocrites. And
how many Christians have you heard say,
"I get more love and respect from my
unbelieving friends than I do from my
believing friends."
Right?
We're all guilty of this. I mean, even
the recent fiasco of what happened
between David and I, even though I was
calling out someone for publicly
sinning. Look, guys, you can hate me.
Apostate prophet has not repented. I'm
sorry. He can hate me. He said, his wife
said he left her and he said he's
falling in love with a woman who's not
his wife and he's not even officially
divorced as a professing Christian.
Brethren, I'm sorry. You can hate me.
May God forgive him and forgive me and
save me from my hypocrisy. That's
adultery,
right?
All right. And then if they believe the
father sent him, here it is. What does
that result in? John 17:8. For the words
which you have given me, I've given to
them, meaning the disciples, and they
received them and knew for sure that I
came from you. They have believed that
you sent me. So guys, if believing and
knowing the father sent the son
results in eternal life,
then is Jesus saying he wants the world
to be saved? And the way the world will
be saved
is
when they see Christians perfectly love
one another and united one with one
another as the Godhead is that will
convince the world to know and believe
the father sent him sent Jesus.
Okay. Is it clear now how the Trinity
purposes to save the world through the
Christian church and their unity and
love and witness?
Okay, you understood the heart of our
Lord. So then when you have the ancient
churches
trying to come together and meet with
one another and see if they can bring
about healing
and show greater love and agree to
disagree without anatizing one another.
Why do you see this as a work of Satan?
Now when I was an anti-atholic, I saw
this as a work of Satan. But why
you see this as a work of Satan?
Do you not want to honor the triune God?
Because your divisions in reality are
based on metaphysical concepts,
assumptions about nature
that God has never explicitly
revealed
that we know. It's thus sayeth the Lord,
but Christians wrestling and struggling
with the philosophical and logical
categories and language and challenges
that they faced at that time to do the
best they could. And some Christians
chose to use a different way of
expressing the same truth because
they're dealing with a different group,
speaking a different language in a
different culture.
You understand?
Do we know absolutely infallibly with
absolute infallible certainty
how to express the divine and human in
Christ?
Should we say one composite nature and a
composite will? And this is thus sayeth
the Lord. Or is it okay to go beyond
that and say two natures, two wills, and
separately united one person? You
understand where I'm getting at?
I just want to hammer that point now. Do
you see why I don't
add to the fuel of hatred and division
among you ancient churches?
Why?
Because the Lord,
who's going to hold me accountable for
all the damage I did for all those years
when I bashed these churches,
wants of me to agree to disagree in
areas where we don't have explicit,
unambiguous, thus sayeth the Lord
warrant for saying that's the wrong way
to articulate the apostatic union.
Okay, I I just want to hammer this
point. I didn't plan to talk about this.
It just happened.